education really seems to alter the
women's sex life whereas the men are not
all that different what's the change
that it makes to women's sex lives one
would say education exposes people to
new ideas and new practices religion is
another way the most religious versus
the least religious women have quite
different sex drives whereas the men are
almost depressingly similar have you got
any idea why you think that might be the
more educated women try a lot more
things do a lot more things they are
much less traditional and conservative
whereas with religion the less she is
open to trying these different practices
two powerful sets of social forces
pushing in opposite directions on the
sex drive and both having a bigger
effect on women than on men